ich treffe michailo podoljak in seinem
Büro im Präsidentenpalast in Kiew seit
dem Beginn des Krieges gehört er zum
engeren Kreis des Präsidenten die
Schuhsammlung am Boden ist symbolisch
für den Ausnahmezustand in dem auch er
seit elf Monaten lebt
muss war mir das Gebäude wir haben vor
drei vier Monaten über andere Themen
geredet aber heute reden wir darüber
dass die europäische panzerkoalition
keine Sache von ferner Zukunft ist
sondern eine Sache von Hier und Jetzt
Präsident ihr Präsident sie selbst die
gesamte politische Elite hat so oft
wahrscheinlich tausende Male die
westliche Staatengemeinschaft um Waffen
gebeten
haben sie es nicht langsam satt oder
sehen Sie Resultate
hier ist der Resultat die
costajana
gebericia
man muss erklären was das für ein Krieg
ist
zweitens erklären warum die
Unterstützung der Ukraine wichtig ist
dass das kein Geschenk an die Ukraine
ist und nichts Abstraktes
sondern das ist auch der Kampf des
Westens für die eigene Freiheit
Russland gewinnt wird Russland nicht
aufhören und denken dass es weiter töten
kann und dafür nicht bestraft wird
wir werden weiter nach Waffen fragen wir
brauchen das nicht nur um die Krim zu
befreien damit wäre der Krieg ja schon
beendet wir sind zusammen in einer
Koalition das ist die Koalition die
unsere Lebensweise verteidigt wirklich
konkret was ist das Ziel dieses Krieges
sehen Sie eine Perspektive für
Verhandlungen mit Russland
und was ist überhaupt die Perspektive
wie die Perspektive
Perspektive
was für Verhandlungen Russland sagt
jeden zweiten Tag lasst uns
Verhandlungen beginnen sie sagen aber
gleichzeitig dass wir die Forderungen
erfüllen müssen ihre Forderungen und
diese Forderungen klingen wie folgt
erstens wir haben euch einen Teil eures
Landes annektiert ihr müsst auf eure
außenpolitische Souveränität verzichten
wo und wie ihr leben dürfen
drittens ihr müsst dann auf eure
historische und kulturelle Entwicklung
verzichten
wir werden entscheiden welche politische
Struktur die Ukraine haben wird wir
meinen zum Beispiel dass die Regierung
von silenski dann gehen muss
wir meinen dass ihr nur russisch
sprechen sollt ihr müsst vergessen dass
ihr eine andere Identität habt dass sie
gar keine Russen seid dass Sie unsere
Denkmäler aufstellt die uns in Russland
gefallen
sie sagen wir werden eure Beamten
korrupieren wir werden euch nicht
erlauben eine Staatsgrenze zu haben wir
werden euch nicht erlauben euch mit
eurer Wirtschaft zu beschäftigen danach
wenn wir all das machen werdet ihr
langsam sterben weil wir Druck auf euch
ausüben es wird ständig interne
Instabilität geben
ihr werdet ständig Befürchtungen über
die Stufe des Krieges haben
das heißt wenn wir uns jetzt zum
Verhandlungsprozess mit der Russischen
Föderation bereit erklären müssten wir
unterzeichnen den Tod der Ukraine
hinzunehmende Prozess
jetzt
wenn wir dann über Waffen reden sagen
wir schaut mal der Verhandlungsprozess
ist sehr genau wenn ein Land auf das
Hoheitsgebiet des anderen kommt und dort
Zivilisten tötet müssen wir so einen
Krieg gewinnen damit wir jeden
kriminellen ob Soldat oder nicht auf die
Anklagebank setzen können
Verhandlungen sind möglich aber erst
dann wenn Russland den Krieg verliert
weil in jedem anderen Format und das hat
auch Kanzler Scholz gesagt wird der
Konflikt nicht beendet werden können das
sagt der öffentlich der Kanzler Scholz
der Konflikt wird weitergehen jetzt habe
ich die Frage an Sie wollt ihr permanent
einen Konflikt auf dem europäischen
Kontinent
offensichtlich lebt die politische Elite
in Russland nicht die moderne
Lebensweise das heißt also wenn wir
diesen Krieg nicht richtig beenden wird
alles erodieren auch in Deutschland
in Kürze dauert der Krieg ein Jahr in
welcher Etappe befindet sich dieser
Krieg wenn man überhaupt von Etappen
sprechen kann Qualität bei tapam
mustangabetapa man kann über Etappen
sprechen
mathematisch und auch hinsichtlich der
Ereignisse auf dem Schlachtfeld jetzt
ist die Wände
das nennt man bei uns vor dem
Sonnenaufgang ist es am dunkelsten jetzt
ist die dunkelste Zeit in diesem Krieg
jetzt hat Russland alle Masken fallen
lassen jetzt sagen Sie direkt wir werden
die Ukraine vernichten Russland macht
das ganz offen
mit Raketen die Hochhäuser treffen das
was in Solidar geschieht wo die ganze
Stadt vernichtet wird und so weiter
das Zeug davon dass Russland jetzt aufs
Ganze geht alles was es hat alle
Ressourcen sind in diesem Krieg
geschickt worden und wir befinden uns
jetzt da wo wir unsere Position halten
müssen um Russland danach eine
endgültige Niederlage zuzufügen das ist
der Höhepunkt in diesem Krieg
Kombination
wie schauen Sie auf den 24 Februar
erwarten Sie irgendwelche besonderen
Ereignisse
bitte weiteres es kann passieren
Herr Putin ist bedauerlicherweise nicht
fähig kritisch Ereignisse zu betrachten
und auch Informationen er wurde lange
Zeit überschätzt und das wichtigste ist
man sollte nicht der Angst erliegen egal
vor wem leider hatten europäische
Regierungschefs oft Angst
er ist berechenbar und primitiv er lebt
in einer Parallelwelt in der es nicht
viel Intellekt stattdessen viel
Symbolismus der schamanischen und
heidnischen
offiziellen Datum ein verbrecherisches
Zeichen er benimmt sich wenn man das
vergleichen kann wie ein Verrückter
Verbrecher
und er will das mit einem Ereignis in
Verbindung setzen wir rechnen also mit
dem Versuch den Krieg zu eskalieren
unsere Territorien zu beschießen und so
weiter aber prinzipiell kann das nicht
viel ändern alles was Russland könnte
hat es schon gemacht
haben Sie eine Idee wie man diesen Krieg
beenden kann
wir haben Ideen
das ist eine Frage der Ressource
wenn wir 400 Panzer haben können wir
diesen Krieg innerhalb von Monaten
beenden man muss diese Ressourcen
kalkulieren und das als Paket zur
Verfügung stellen als Gesamtpaket und
dann werden wir das innerhalb von
Monaten beenden es geht nicht um zwei
Monate aber um fünf sechs sieben es ist
auch nicht so wichtig das ist kein Krieg
für Jahre Attribute den lang andauernden
Krieg wird es geben wenn es so wie jetzt
weitergeht man bekommt ein paar wenige
Waffen aber das reicht nicht um den
Feind zu vernichten
also liegt jetzt alles in den Händen der
westlichen Länder ist dran
es wurde eine Koalition gegen das
naziland gebildet das Russische
Föderation heißt es ist wichtig wer die
Führungsrolle übernommen hat es ist sehr
wichtig auf der richtigen Seite der
Geschichte zu stehen heute scheinen es
Kleinigkeiten zu sein in 10 50 100
Jahren aber werden diese richtigen
Positionen eine wichtige Rolle spielen
nicht alles hängt vom Westen ab es hängt
auch von der Ukraine ab wie wir uns
verhalten was mehr machen werden wie wir
Entschlossenheit demonstrieren es hängt
davon ab wie die politischen Eliten ihre
Rolle und ihren Platz in der Geschichte
verstehen
die sich unsere Kinder unsere Enkel
einmal an uns erinnern werden wir wissen
wie man sich an uns erinnern wird aber
ich möchte auch dass sie im Westen in
guter Erinnerung bleiben werden